hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to there's
some people that just keep making
appearances Garriga stylus central
people at Shaquille O'Neal pee-wee
Herman a pagoda and of course the
Austrian beef sandwich himself Arnold
Schwarzenegger what is it about him
anyway
he's so goofy and yet so likable such a
bad actor and yet so entertaining you
can't stop watching him no matter how
hard you try well if there's any movie
that can make the Arnold formula seem
old and stale apart from all those other
ones its last action here
you think the director of diehard and
predator would know something about
keeping audiences entertained but then
John McTiernan is big budget for fest we
find that even the most action-packed
director can make the most doll unfunny
and creatively mislead of pictures now I
know what you're thinking Arnold
Schwarzenegger make a bad movie surely
you jest well let's take a look and see
why last action euro is a last action
zero
trust me that's a lot funnier than most
of the jokes in this movie so we opened
up with the movie slamming us in the
face literally
violets cinema we see a bunch of cops
lined up around a building where some
psycho is holding a bunch of children
hostage who could possibly save the day
but then cook it down it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger playing cop Jack Slater
who has to deal with what most movie
content to deal with the typical
shouting boss give them a sit and wait
for the where hostage negotiator last
time you pour this Josh did it bug go
try it
he then once across a pointless Tina
Turner cameo thanks Tina
your checks in the mail as he fixes one
cop who doesn't want to let him pass hey
you want to be a farmer here's a couple
of acres kid yeah I'm sorry could you
keep back you want to be a farmer here's
a couple of acres what does that mean
I mean Arnold's lines are corny but they
usually make sense
is it because acre sounds like eggs is
it because he kicked him so far it's
like the distance of an acre arse balls
the acres I mean what's the shake
Arnold you can't just sing random
phrases I expect them to magically be
funny you got to think about them first
it's like saying you want to be an
astronaut tricks are for kids so he gets
to the rooftop where we see the psycho
holding the kids hostage gave my word of
honour he could watch you die Oh Steven
right what did you do to yourself I'm
living on a one-way dead-end street and
of course it just so happens that one of
the boys being held hostage is Slater's
son now lose the gun
all right I'm unarmed so let the boy go
let the boy go you know he has a name
being his father I thought you might be
privy to that information but it turns
out the movie is well just that a movie
being watched by a whiny little
protagonist named Danny Danny is friends
but the projection is at a movie theater
played by Robert rocky the new Jack
Slater opens this weekend at the
audition so being such a good friend
press key offers him an advanced
screening of the next Jack Slater movie
as long as he finally starts going back
to school which he's been skipping out
on quite often there they show films of
a lesser caliber like Hamlet with
Laurence Olivier the hack
and so he goes to heaven just Toit God
Shakespeare's like the worst writer ever
so Danny starts daydreaming about what
the film would be like it Arnold was it
stay thy hand fair Prince who said I'm
fair enjoy it while you can Arnold
that's as close to Hamlet if you're ever
going again to be or not to be not to be
vanity by name is insert clever pun here
so he goes home and gets yelled at by
his mom right before she has to head out
to work he sits around watching some TV
does boring stuff and then finally gets
ready to go see the movie so he gets
ready to head out the door away you
alone okay hello sudden dark turn
tough guy do it go ahead do it
okay movie this is pretty fucked up
right here so he handcuffs him in the
bathroom and continues to roam the place
you got jack no jewelry no VCR maybe I
should try robbing rich people go
fishing Vigo so after that pointlessly
disturbing detour Danny heads to the
movie theater where Kraske is waiting is
the pre renewal oh just a minute young
man
aren't we forgetting something take it
and hope I got just the one when I spot
your age Harry Houdini played this
theater and he made a gesture who did he
did like this and all of a sudden this
was in his hair behind this hair this is
a magic didn't it was given to me by the
best magician in India and it was given
to him by the best magician in Tibet
it's okay then we already have one
strange doctor we don't need another to
passport to another world it was mine
and now it's your right time on our
sonic SEZ
hey kids strangers may offer you all
sorts of things to get you to come with
them like movies magical tickets and
line of other horse gym but chances are
they're just trying to touch your
bathing suit area and that's no good
still if a stranger especially Robert
prosody tries to touch your chilly down
just get out so he lifts the ticket
which I guess was made out of Tinker
Bell blood as he starts showing the
movie for Danny to watch we see a guy
being interrogated by a mob boss played
oddly enough by Anthony Quinn's do you
want me to make them operate on you I
would make an Anthony Quinn Joe but none
of you would get it we then cut to Jack
Slater entering his home as he sees his
old friend conveniently right before he
dies Tony Vivaldi and the Tyrell Emma
are joining forces Oh Frank Frank what
the hell you can kill him watching
Arnold do drama really bad bad of course
the bob was wired to the card somehow
two days to return
did the saxophone just laugh at it
so the Chase Begins higher goons are
sent to shoot ups later when suddenly
the magic ticket actually transports
Danny into the movie who how are you
I'm Danny man again I'm a cheap you're
driving with no hand thing is easy to
practice a lot I bet you're doing all
that my butt cheeks have their own
license is that guy Kona phrase freedom
the bad puns the voice the hard walk
movie so he plays chicken with this
truck with somehow explodes before
hitting the building as he crashes into
me he'll show
so the kid is taken back to the police
station where it comes across Sharon
Stone from basic instinct and robber
Patrick from Terminator 2 you know
moving I'm not sure if you know this but
um cameos have to make sense just
because those two people work in movies
doesn't mean that necessarily makes
sense to have them in your movie I mean
it's like having a car to camp running
around all over the place was that are
you serious
what there that doesn't make any sense
he's supposed to be back in duty it was
only suspended for a month nobody know
there is no reason a cartoon cat should
be there and it's like saying Little
Richard's in the movie I've been Jordan
jean-claude Van Damme I will never miss
the premiere for Saget Jim Belushi I
just want to be there when it happens
I see hair look it deals done right
Humphrey Bogart is looking at you
Chevy Chase and Damon Wayans walking
side-by-side what's going on pointless
random cameos and I'm the twilight zone
honey
movie just because you can have someone
in your belt doesn't mean you should
it's like having no know that person's
name they might spontaneously jump out
on somebody's anus let's just keep
watching the movie and be dominant so I
guess the joke behind some of these
strange cameos is that every cop at the
station is supposed to be delightfully
mismatched you know like those buddy cop
movies you see all the time so one God
might be teamed up with a rabbi a chubby
slob will be teamed up with a neat freak
and yes one cop gets hooked up with a
cartoon cat I'm getting a flea band
later join me while the idiot could be
kind of clever it still makes no sense
why are these mismatched cops in this
buddy movie I mean you don't see Mel
Gibson - Danny Glover teaming up with
Chris Tucker and Jackie Chan yet but the
boy still remains by the movies just
deal with one pair of bunnies not five
or six no other movies work that way no
one likes a smartass
so Slater gets called in to be yelled at
by the chief as the key keep pointing
out all the cliches pretty much before
the audience can I'm willing to bet that
everyone has a 555 number there are no
unattractive women here how is just in a
real police station and this is nice
nice kid leaked the plat holes to me
okay it's my job so he goes into a
blockbuster video store trying to prove
that there's an actor called Arnold
Schwarzenegger and that he's made dozens
of hit films but he finds I have to
admit is kind of funny no it isn't
possible yeah yeah I'll be back the last
of the beasts identify you know I just
want to go the distance
I mean where are the ordinary everyday
women they don't exist because this is a
movie oh this is California and one day
I will govern it ha ha ha
so we get some scenes of them talking
then some more scenes of them talking
and then some more scenes of them
talking you just revolutionized in time
you know guys speaking isn't exactly
short to make a strong point
can't you give almost done or bombs or
even a free suit I don't care just get
on something finally they're going to
visit the bad guy in his deadly assassin
make no mistake they are exceptionally
well-trained movie are you on drugs so
yeah we don't really get any answers
then they just decide to leave oh good
how wonderful thank you for that boobie
I really thought you're gonna fuck up
there and do something exciting for a
minute please tell me there's another
long drawn-out scene of just two people
talking yes yes I am so badly to think
we could be wasting our time with
gunfire explosions and exciting chase
scenes but no uninteresting crime plot
and a whiny little brat with curly hair
is far more interesting her rock her
fucking rock blow something up or a hot
chick if that helps - so Slater drops
off the key with his incredibly
attractive daughter as he drives off to
have a flashback he remembers back to
his son who it turns out what's murdered
- Weiss for some reason as the movies
that are decided as they're suddenly
approached by the assassin
you want hair on your head stop Wow
that'd be really threatening in fifth
grade okay oh hey lady I don't think you
understand the purpose of scream you
scream when you're in trouble
you're not the damsel from the Dover
boys cartoon let's later arrives to help
hi alright that's one cool seat so they
had a little fight as the bad guys write
off in the car but Danny grabs a girl's
bike which belongs to the grown-up
daughter as he hits them off at the past
chicken it is kid what the hell is wrong
with you your honor girls bye they're in
a fucking car do the math it's gonna
work it's a movie I'm a good guy just
I've got to work
oh shit funny comedy psychic and rather
unfunny one that we'd like to see you
get pulverized
so the kid still thinking the whole
movie bit is funny tries to prove to
Slater again that this is all a film so
this grow up just say this one Lord you
can't you can't possibly say because
this movie is pg-13 together not online
fuck shit titicaca so we go back to the
police station where once again we get a
screaming fest from the angry chief you
better get busy down the beach goddammit
Jesus Christ he's turning into the micro
machine guy this is micro between mantas
mo Cooper's miniature motorcade of Micro
Machines each one has dramatic
developers from stupendous islands of
different takes our boy she wields
Michael McKean car that's right he could
never beat a grand theft auto before
boys and by the way yes that is steam
coming out of his ears did I mention
that this movie was pg-13 as in no one
above the age of 13 would find this
funny give me your badge
so Slater is laid off which of course
means they're going to stop the crime
boss on their own somehow they find out
that this body and a funeral is going to
explode with some sort of nerve gas I
don't know just play along and Slater
and Danny are confronted by his old
partner play by F Murray Abraham sorry
jack I didn't want it to go down this
way but I haven't played the good guy in
a movie yet so here we are thanks yeah
are you an idiot
you made the classic zombie mistake do I
explain so much shut up but Quinn gets
the drop on the kid as they chained our
two heroes together I have to go and
establish my alibi
honey revenge I look forward to you
totally forgetting this performance
they're saved by the cartoon cat yep
shorts a nigger movie where he's saved
by a fucking trash as he goes up to the
funeral and tries to get the body away
from the people this man's not dead
can somebody help this man here
look elephant so while Danny is probably
wondering why he could have gotten
transported into Debbie Does Dallas he
may just operate a crane it helps
Slater's get off the roof in one of the
strangest slow-mo shots ever this is
what I like to call the wily coyote I do
not actually fall until I realized there
is nothing supporting me this Tyler
slapstick comedy was originated in the
1940s Warner Brothers was beginning to
make its market time I was just about to
tell them about the Golden Age of cinema
animation I eat you eat you are so they
saved the day while the assassin guy
gets the magic ticket and starts to
discover exactly what he can do with it
I can move through parallel worlds and
anat ain't stealing whatever I want but
not before Slater politely knocks at the
door
if uncoiling
don't move alright Slater I'll go
quietly the hell you will
we're going to have an exciting time I
just want the feeling conclusion this is
for my daughter's black-tie usually when
they do that it leaves a hole there was
supposed to be an earth-shattering
kaboom those later and Danny travel into
the real world where Slater discovers
things don't work quite like he thought
they would
here's another exposure
one wrote my acting it doesn't seem to
fly here nobody finds you credible they
just laugh with my accent so just as you
is saying to yourself shooting this
movie be over by now the film prattles
on mostly is Slater just mopes around
and faces the reality he's a fictional
character
he's unite miss the rest of your life
but your fictional so who cares I'm
sorry but I don't find it so new and
exciting to discover that my whole life
has been a damn movie yeah this is the
real world with magic tickets that suck
you in the realms of fantasy it's an
everyday occurrence so through a long
long long long series of boring events
they finally realize that the assassin
is going to attack an Arnold
Schwarzenegger's premiere of the new
Jack Slater Benedict is gonna kill
Schwarzenegger what sneaker was Slavin
bingo bingo except no that makes no
sense but screw it let's just get to the
climax of the sucker
so the assassin goes and brings back
that Stephen bright guy as he plans to
use him to kill Schwarzenegger the actor
rip rip come here what if Brooke fascia
we're tonight
well I just wanted to tell people that
they can save a lot of money by
switching to Geico even a caveman can do
it oh by the way this is where we get a
lot of we cameo as I mentioned before
they walk in from the camera and then
wonder what they did to deserve such a
piss-poor treatment but we all know what
Van Damme did but I digress so he tries
to kill Arnold and fails but he kidnaps
the kid and takes him to the rooftop he
for the real world being nothing like a
movie we've just seen this is in fact
looking a lot like a movie with Jesse
it's not between you and me let the boy
go and we played this number before
haven't we checked cure just angry
because I have 12 more teeth than the
average human being
later defeats the psycho but then gets
hunted down by the assassin
well of course reveals his evil plan you
want back it up
I'll fetch it Dracula I can get King
I'm a surprise party for that old Hitler
Hannibal Lecter can do the K today all I
have to do it's not my fingers and
they'll be here that's actually a pretty
cool planet Holy Smoke
I can't wait to see the possibilities I
come out of it oh gosh just run the only
cool premise in the entire film
fucking cock blocker you think you're
funny don't you
so Arnold gets the gun and shoot the bad
guy who's somehow explodes again real
world isn't it fascinating as the ticket
Falls and actually releases the grim
reaper from the Seventh Seal
because yeah everyone who sees Last
Action Hero is going to know what the
hell the Seventh Seal is as Danny tries
to take an interest later and get him
back into the movie why because in the
film world his injury would only be
considered a flesh wound and apparently
not kill him
so death plague oddly enough by Ian
McKellen gives Danny some helpful advice
if I were you I might be looking for the
other half of the ticket one ticket to
roll them all
one ticket to fight over it so he finds
the ticket and gets him back into the
movies where the doctors fix him up so
he can go back to duty the kid has had
an amazing adventure he realized with
the prosti character and they all live
happily ever after
there is just one tiny detail that they
overlooked the fucking grim reapers are
no hoax I mean we never saw him go back
into the movie and we even saw him kill
a few people in the real world isn't
this I don't know a big fucking deal
maybe it was meant to be saved for the
sequel Last Action Hero to death takes a
holiday
but look away we never saw it cuz this
film tanked at the box office and why
should it it's dull
I mean it is so boring granted some of
the ideas have promised and there are
one or two jokes at work but mostly it's
a very clumsy boring action film my
advice I'd rather listen to that put
that cookie down remakes a million times
before ever watching this movie again
that cookie wouldn't put that cookie
wouldn't what
get down down down hook it down down
down you don't have cookie down
you